what's up everybody welcome back to the
cops Wonder podcast I I did read the
comments of what you guys suggested for
the name and a lot of people I just
called the cause of Wonder podcast I'm
like yeah I mean yeah yeah basically
right right yeah I mean that and that is
100 what it is uh what's up I'm Warren
um from the cosmic wonder the voice you
hear every day and the face you see
sometimes and with me is wait which went
this way law oh nice nice orientation
podcast hello everyone
so quick quick note
if you've been enjoying the podcast
or the channel be sure to subscribe
because both law and I have received uh
episodes of Loki season two we have
watched some episodes of Lucky season
two we cannot say anything about it at
all until what October 2nd
I thought it was the fourth the fourth
we're gonna double we're gonna double
check that right now I got that I'll
double check that right now
um okay look it no social embargo lifts
Monday October 2nd gotcha uh so we can't
say anything till 9 00 PM Pacific time
and a review embargo which means we can
just pretty much talk about it all we
want
is October 3rd at 6 00 a.m so we'll
record we're gonna record our entire
podcast just talking about Loki season
two before it comes out we'll probably
do half and half
um
first part not talking about spoilers
obviously for the people who don't you
know hear those obviously but we can
talk about spoilers so maybe like the
second half or the last quarter of it
we'll talk about spoilers for the people
who want some juice the juice right the
juicy Theory time basically yeah exactly
exactly so
I I was gonna say something but I can't
we can't say anything about it but we
will have some episodes where we do
extensively say things about it uh so
stay tuned yeah stay tuned stay tuned
not sure if people heard yesterday
uh news was announced that Marvel
Studios is starting to look for writers
for the X-Men movie which is like
that's what we've been waiting for hell
yeah right I mean oh law do you have a
favorite X-Men character I don't think
I've ever asked you yes I do he's right
there on my wall actually there's
Nightcrawler oh night crawler all right
all right a big night crawler guy in the
comics I'm a big Cyclops guy I also like
Havoc there's so many X-Men is such a
great series there's so many good runs
so all I love like the different ones
like even Uncanny X-Men I really like as
a kid
um like ultimate X-Men even I enjoyed
like I I don't know and then the the art
and stuff like if you're talking about I
don't know in fortnite I use the Rogue
skin I use skylog I use Gambit I love I
love it the psylocke Skins dope
especially with like the pickaxe that's
like a guy named hot too yeah yeah yeah
that's one of the top tier fortnite
skins right now
the Fantastic Four were the first comic
book I ever picked up like really
original Stan Lee one like it would be
like a trade of it right the second but
then the immediate next stuff was like a
X-Men storyline about Nightcrawler and I
just like fell in love with the X-Men
because like oh there's all the TV show
but yeah I'm a big X-Men fan for sure I
wish I could remember the first comic I
picked up but I don't there was this
comic uh store in Texas where my
family's from and I remember as a kid my
uncle would take me there and we would
just get some come my uncle who he
actually passed away recently but he was
a huge I'm I'm thinking of that because
I'm like wondering what happened to all
of his collectible stuff because I don't
think his kids were too like big into it
but he was just the biggest like man his
house was so cool you go in his house
and it's like it's like like my studio
time's like 20 like literally he'd been
collecting stuff for such a long time
and uh I guess I I partly have him to
think for uh for me getting into for
Comics actually
um my dad to think for getting me into
movies but and he had so much and I was
so young I don't remember like the first
comic he ever got me unfortunately but I
do remember reading a lot of X-Men uh
yeah I mean
everyone's like oh is your favorite
X-Men angel I'm like why because his
name Warren and I'm worried
yeah I'm like uh he's not my he is one
of my favorites I really like him and I
actually do think like
like Marvel should probably do a true
X-Men first Class to introduce the X-Men
maybe like that thought has been in my
mind recently I'll be honest with you
that's exactly what I'm hoping for right
I think that's yeah Iceman Beast you
know yeah gray Cyclops Cyclops Cyclops
the leader Angel yeah I don't care if
it's set in the 60s or like no not the
60s I'm sorry uh like in the 90s or
something or like the 80s and then so
that way they age up or maybe they do it
as adults and then Xavier's School is
like really young and we see that
develop yeah but like I'm I as much as I
want to see like all of these guys I
want hints of them for sure right yeah
there should be a a ton of mutants
you know like we should see the the the
scale of that but I I there's like a
purest side of me that's like because in
X-Men first Class great movie but I
really wanted to see like like I don't
know there's something about that
classic that classic
yeah and
and it's like Professor X is kind of
like their father so in in that you know
what I mean but like Cyclops like later
it's it's it's there's so much potential
but I want
so this is what we're going to talk
about I wonder how they're going to like
introduce them in the MCU it's very
clear that they've hinted X-Men or at
least the mutant Gene exist in people in
our current MCU because like like I
think our last podcast we talked about
the reboot last couple of podcasts we
talked about three but I think yeah um
and it's like okay is there's rumors
that the Fantastic Four movie is going
to be set in another universe is it the
same for the X-Men and then after it's
like a combined universe and now we have
these other like Legacy X-Men characters
like is our Professor X gonna be from a
different universe and then all of a
sudden he's taking care of these New
Mutants not the new Mutant team but
right new X-Men mutants coming into the
MCU all of a sudden he's like oh yeah no
we had mutants in our universe you're
just now like your Gene is basically
just now being ignited and now you have
mutants let me create my school here and
I'll coach everybody yeah like is that
that's one way to do it I I would
actually be kind of like it's it's I
feel like it's a really clean way to do
that
but I would be like a little like she I
would feel cheap right right right right
because I want to see how their Roots if
they tie into what we know already right
because it almost feels like an easy
write-off to just be like and then the
universes collided you know like and I I
want to see them kind of like skirt
around that yeah who knows
and that's like the thing is like we
want okay so I shouldn't say we I want
origin stories right like I and you know
what I was thinking actually recently I
was like you know what I would actually
like I would like to see a good handful
of X-Men projects of Magneto being good
before his Feud with Xavier Xavier I
think that would be a cool spin right
because we did get X-Men first Class
where you know they're friends for you
know after movie whatever it may be but
then on out every other movie is you
know
Xavier and Magneto yeah and then even
with the original X-Men films right
they're already pinned against each
other right we come into it where it's
really like you know like a Wolverine
and like a rogue kind of origin story
well I shouldn't even say origin story
you say that though because like we get
a glimpse of like well how how Beast
kind of came to be in a sense right like
they handle that decently we've seen
Jean Gray a ton of times but like have
you ever seen the plane accident with
Scott and his brother that like causes
you know causes him to ignite his powers
like right I want to see all that stuff
still too you know what I mean yeah uh I
want to see how Iceman developed the
like from the Snowman to like ice form
you know what I mean like see that
process too
well no that's a good
that's a good point because it's like
going back to what I was saying before
if you take the like Multiverse
universes colliding part out of it maybe
you can just say like well nothing like
really and this is like I don't know if
this is a cop-out or a good storytelling
it's like complete opposite sides like
do we say like the snap activated these
genes that just weren't awakened yet in
a human population right you could you
could make that a story I mean they did
they did something similar well like not
energy but they did something in like
you know Agents of Shield that's how the
Inhumans came in humans right right and
it's so it could be a good way to do it
uh that would explain Kamala and stuff
but like well that's what you meant to
say are they getting really in humans
like because they already retcon Kamala
yeah so maybe they just don't see
foresee themselves using in humans in
the future maybe the Inhumans become
like a faction of mutants you know what
I mean right exactly
um because like in Miss Marvel we see
that like other realm right like where
she pulls that energy from right right
and I'm wondering like is that could
that be like ganosha like like a portal
to where that place a lot of people you
know that yeah yeah you know or maybe
they already exist in the universe and
they they're living on ganoia we just
don't see it in the same way we don't
see what conda or Atlanta
you know
and another thought kind of that like
maybe maybe the like the X-Men team like
if Xavier is there Magneto's there maybe
it's like
maybe Xavier kind of erased everyone's
memories
I've thought about that too right and
it's not time yet
and and that could bring the Magneto you
know conflict with the humans and
everything into the the picture as well
yeah because he can be like it's never
time they'll always hate us right like
Xavier's like it's not time yet people
aren't ready for us yet they're not
ready for a super powered people but now
after everything that's happened
in the in every in in the infinity sag
in the multi Multiverse Saga up to now
it's like well maybe now we can and you
can see how like Magneto would be like
this is it we're done like these people
are out here they've saved the world
like people accept them we're coming out
yeah but it's obviously I love that but
I would almost almost look to see it a
step further where like if he'd erase
the memory maybe like Magneto was on the
front lines for some of those events
that we just didn't see and then and
then the world just forgotten the same
way they forgot about Spider-Man you
know what I mean dude that's actually a
really good idea and that's why he's
pissed you know right like look what I
did I saved it before yeah yeah yeah
yeah and no one knows about us like I
would I would be pissed too that's like
a great way to like kind of refreshen
his hatred towards humans it is and you
could you could split like the event
well some you could split the Avengers
from the X-Men because it's like Iron
Man doesn't have powers right
you know some of them
were like genetically
experimented on to get they weren't born
with them right they're all human at the
end of the day you know what I mean
right exactly like except for of course
right right that's and that's another
Point magnificent but like even like a
freaking God like can come down from a
freaking entire different yeah right and
people are just chilling because he's so
good looking like
yeah like they sent the dang Destroyer
down and I killed that thing in an
instant because I could control it you
know they should give that guy four
movies yeah right
you got Deadpool there so and stuff like
that yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
and I'm curious about like the jokes
they're gonna make in Deadpool 3 but I
am uh I I would I gotta say I was kind
of shocked to
to hear that they are making a movie
because I almost thought
and I and I haven't decided what I would
prefer if it's like do I prefer
them to go to introduce individual
mutants and build that up to an X-Men
team like The Avengers like you know
Captain America Iron Man yeah we'll
throw the Hulk in there I guess it's a
solo movie
um the solo Thor movie and then they
come together as The Avengers as you
know I was almost wondering like okay
we'll get the Scott one right and we'll
Xavier Magneto maybe that's one movie or
two different movies right Jean Gray
like you know
and then they come together to be the
X-Men
and I actually I don't think Magneto
should be the villain for a bit because
we've we've done that for years now
years years years years decades so
I I don't know if I would like the
origin way better but I I kind of did
think they were going to do that because
it's a tried and true method for them
but the Avengers so so hearing that
there's a movie I was very surprised I'm
not disappointed obviously I'm very very
excited but I was really surprised to
hear that
there's a lot of ways to do it it's
interesting because there's so much
story with X-Men and there's so many
ways to adapt it and like you said there
are there's like a ton of stories within
the X-Men where it's like we could just
focus on Bobby for a while we could just
focus on Scott you know Hank McCoy like
he had a great little run in the in the
like you know the first class the first
class ones yeah yeah but then we all
know that franchise went off the rails
and I'm sure Deadpool 3 will like
all over it but like going to it's
totally going to but like but it started
off so pretty strong in my opinion like
Days of Future Past was like an
interesting adaptation of a really
classic storyline and I liked it a lot
and then first class was really good
um the
and like Logan was really good but it
but like everything else around it was
doo-doo yeah and so it's like I as an
expert fan Phoenix I just want it to
work and I feel like
I don't know it's been we've been in
Marvel for a very long time we said this
on one of the previous podcast episodes
the X-Men are like a really great entry
point to get excited again about the MCU
in like a refreshing way because it's
like it's been a while since the fox
projects those are dead and gone and
maybe even exemplified within Canon you
know what I mean like right who knows
what they're gonna do with those
characters uh but like yeah I'm I'm
looking forward to the X-Men but I am
interested to see what what movie means
in the end you know what I mean well yes
exactly you know you kind of just make a
point like
the movie's being exemplified like who
knows what Deadpool 3 is gonna do yeah
right who knows how that's really going
to affect everything some thoughts you
know what I think Deadpool 3 is going to
be the real Multiverse of Madness it is
it's like I've been calling it in my
head Deadpool 3 cameos of Madness like
oh yeah yeah like I actually really
think that is what it's going to be I
have thoughts Deadpool kills the
Multiverse yeah Deadpool kills the fox
Universe yeah yeah how do you
how do you get how do you take
how do you separate yourself from what
was while at the same time honoring what
it was because that's what Sean Levy
said they were basically going to do
that's what Kevin feige wants to do yeah
so yeah talk about that in just a bit
but first I wanted to say a big thank
you to Elgato for sponsoring this video
if you guys are listening to the podcast
uh the mic my XLR mic from Elgato is
what you're hearing sound is fantastic
if you're watching all the studio lights
in my studio are Elgato and law is
actually using an Elgato face cam like
right now yeah they're they're fantastic
the lights are also amazing because
they're not hot they do not heat up my
room my other lives my other lights
before they really really were like so
hot and I would sweat and now I'm
wearing a sweatshirt and I'm feeling
fine uh and you can control all the
lights from your phone or
if actually from like a lot of different
things like stream deck and everything
like that but if you want to check out
Elgato we'll put the link to uh my
Elgato stuff in the comments down below
big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days or quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months that's hellofresh.com 50
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50 off
plus 15 off the next two months
now going back to Deadpool uh
I'm I I'm so excited for this movie and
I and I did a video the other day that
was like hey it's okay to get excited
for Deadpool
because a lot of people don't want to to
get let down because the Multiverse of
Madness right because we because what we
really thought Multiverse of Madness was
going to be was like they're going to go
into so many different universes and
every time they go into a universe
they're going to see a variant of some
sort right which it's like yeah sure
they kind of did go through a lot of
different universes for like two seconds
yeah right and it's kind of like and
then they just kind of stayed in one
Universe um
but but Deadpool is almost the opposite
of that well also possibly being the
same thing because we know it's supposed
to be like a road trip for Deadpool and
Wolverine
but from what we've heard right now
a bunch of people from a bunch of
different universes are that are dying
incursions happening are going to be
kind of saved and put into one Universe
kind of like Avengers Secret Wars battle
World sure right
2014-15 version okay
um and
so that's like everyone coming into one
Universe from all the other universes
and I'm not really sure
about the other part but I I think
Deadpool Wolverine are going to be like
traveling different universes as well so
this really is like the Multiverse film
like it sure it's gonna be pretty crazy
I think it was Grace Randolph who said
it's it's gonna be like a Noah's Ark
basically like hey heroes from across
the galaxies right exactly wow right it
sounds really cool and so we know that
Kevin feige's plan is to honor these old
X-Men I call them X-Men Legacy
characters and bring them into
uh the MCU and say goodbye to them
properly so
this is a really good idea because
Deadpool's gonna I've heard Deadpool
is like an Infinity war to end game so
it like like the events directly set up
what is happening in Avengers
right it's almost like there's a bunch
of part ones The Secret Wars right it's
like part 1.1 Deadpool three part 1.2
King Dynasty part 1.3 Doctor Strange
three like I feel like a bunch of things
are gonna happen at the exact same time
and then they go into Secret Wars sure
yeah yeah that's like that's like an
interest I could totally see that
happening because like right just like
based on the conversations were
happening based on the fact that Loki's
coming out
um and everything's dealing with
Multiverse right now right so so it all
it all feels like it's a big setup so
this is probably what you know some
people were saying like where's Marvel
going like this is this is where it's
going where they're going yeah yeah this
is it yeah oh for sure and it's really
exciting it just got even more exciting
with the announcement the X-Men movie
which I'm still like I'm kind of baffled
and I don't know where it's gonna end up
on the timeline which is I feel like
it's such a special special project that
they'll they'll put it in
wherever it needs to be you know once it
feels right because like imagine
sorry go for it well before after Secret
Wars is a big decision that determines a
lot because that'll determine part of
the story yeah yeah because like if this
is a good buy a proper goodbye to those
Fox Legacy characters like you said like
giving Cyclops is due James Marsden you
deserve it but no he deserves it man oh
who deserves it he was a good Cyclops he
just was an underutilized one
um I feel like him as an actor for a
long time was just underutilized he was
always the dude whose girl was being
taken who lost the girl he oh you did a
notebook you know Enchanted yeah
everything Superman Returns
poor guy he was great in jury duty um oh
gosh that's so funny yeah but yeah and
like the Sonic movies now I don't care
what people say those movies are fun
those movies are so good yeah they're
awesome yeah it's just you know I'm not
expecting Martin Scorsese to call it
Cinema but no what no dude is awesome
and he's been I think just over the past
handful of years he's been fantastic
yeah all that to say if it's a proper
goodbye right and New Mutants being an
origin story that that kind of fits in
you know right like oh there's new ones
you know
and I guess that does make the most
sense you actually have a good point
there like if we are saying goodbye it
makes sense to say hello
not picking up
from like another point in the story but
rather starting at the beginning yeah so
with that thought it actually does make
me believe that this is probably face
set
X-Men movies probably face up like the
start and think so right if we're saying
goodbye and we'll say hello like yeah
because because if Secret Wars is the
goodbye yeah then the the next phase
right after phase seven should be the
hello
to the new ones
it's interesting there's two big
families coming up which is like the
mutants and there's it's Fantastic Four
yeah I think that's phase seven you know
like yeah those big those big event
movies maybe or like I don't know how
they're gonna build it out but but I
know that that focus is probably gonna
shift that way like yeah I think the
Avengers take a sideline for a bit yeah
me too they've had you know 10 plus
years of
awesomeness I I don't think they're
gonna I don't think you can ignore them
I don't think you can simply say they're
not there anymore right like no we're
always gonna have Easter eggs and you
know maybe
you know Roadie becomes a president
eventually or something like that right
so well it's like Wolverine it was in
The Avengers you know what I mean like
right yeah I think there's a lot of
crossovers I want to see like just like
in the comics like I remember I was
reading runaways back in the day and I
was like flipping through the pages and
then suddenly Captain America Spider-Man
Wolverine show up trying to like get the
kids back to their parents and I was
just like ah it's so cool because like
just like pop it it's because it looked
legitimate Cameo right yeah I want that
to continue through the MCU that's what
made it special when Falcon showed up in
Ant-Man you know what I mean like yeah
yeah it just ties it all in and they
can't forget about them but I just don't
want to be like oh Julia Louis Dreyfus
is in this one too and it's like yeah or
whatever where's Thor where's Thor yeah
yeah exactly yeah and then there's
things like you know like She-Hulk
becomes takes the thing spot in the
Fantastic Four you know it's important
time in common like there's a lot of
things that they could really do to to
keep those cool big cameos and
crossovers uh all while kind of focusing
on you know newer characters which is
excited in its own but it's so weird how
exciting it would be if you have just
like a few movies about the X-Men
Fantastic Four and then all of a sudden
it's like oh my gosh Thor's here yeah
yeah yeah and you know it would be
really funny for like the newer
Watchers
who maybe haven't watched you know all
the original Marvel stuff it's like that
that's the word from like the OG MCU you
know that's an interesting thought
that's crazy that that's actually going
to be a thing at some point in time
whether that's 10 years from now or or
20 years from now there's going to be
some kids watching the newer MCU going
to see a cameo and gonna go oh is that
Thor like what Thor is this like bro
that's from like the fourth MCU movie
like wow you know oh that's it's sad and
exciting I hope I'm the person to go
it's from the fourth MC
we just gonna we're gonna keep getting
older and we're gonna be that eventually
this this is a uh
this is a uh it's totally off topic but
I saw like a fun fact yesterday that was
like em the amount of I don't even
remember the amount of people older than
you will never increase yeah that's what
it was
oh I guess that makes sense is the
amount of people younger than you will
always increase
but the opposite isn't true completely
off topic but it lightly off top it was
one of those things where I was just
like
like Keanu Reeves
yeah but uh yeah no I mean it is crazy
to think of the MCU that far in advance
yeah like it is it feels really like
I don't know like there's no there's not
a lot of Merit you know like there's no
meat to it it just feels like I'm we're
grasping at possibilities but we need to
see the next couple movies and like what
mute means in the MCU to make like real
real like theaterizations I guess yeah
and again that's where Deadpool 3 comes
in just if it and you know okay so I I
say like I get my hopes up because Sean
Levy came out and you know in an
interview and he was like Hey look there
are all of these fox movies that
happened before We're Not Gonna ignore
those yeah yeah I'm like fantastic that
basically confirms everything every
Insider has said where we're gonna see
you know some original X-Men
um you know Ben Affleck was spotted on
set some people are saying oh he just
went to visit Jennifer Gardner because
his kids were there who knows if he's
returning us uh Daredevil or not but
elektra's gonna be in it yeah yeah I
hope Nick's Nick Cage's Ghostwriter pops
up you know what I mean like if you
really are saving a bunch different
people from different universes like
dude okay save some save some cameos for
secret rewards sure yeah but I but I
also at the same time think like the big
cameos and Secret Wars are gonna be like
Robert Downey Jr returning as an Ironman
variant right and Scarlett Johansson
returning his Black Widow from a
different Universe like I think those
will be really really big
yeah those would be big ones whereas
Deadpool
I mean you know the story Deadpool kills
Marvel universe is you can perfectly
adapt that into Deadpool kills the fox
universe and then at the end he's in the
MCU oh yeah for sure boom you know yeah
that was yeah the Noah's Arc idea is
actually a really cool idea yeah I hope
that's true we'll see because like it is
a big task but like I love Sean Levy I
think I think he has a really great like
he's not such a great job yeah he did a
lot he's just so good with like really
big Concepts I think and then making it
feel really palatable still at the same
time like as a consumer like you're not
lost in the story yeah that's awesome
yeah free guy is a great one didn't he
do Adam project I did do the Adam
project yeah that one actually probably
is a little bit harder to grasp your
head yeah yeah but that one I really
enjoyed one of my favorite Ryan Reynolds
performances but for sure I have a lot
of faith in what Deadpool 3 will be
because is I just think it's gonna be
refreshing to see like a parody of the
MCU now you know that's kind of what it
is yeah yeah yeah and like quick it's
not a side note but quick note
um I'm sorry I don't remember his name
the kid who plays in the atom project
who plays the younger Percy Jackson guy
um
Austin sorry buddy I don't remember
but there's a rumor that kid pool is
going to be in Deadpool 3 and that he
might like
oh because because somebody Walker
Scoville it is it is I remember
um somebody said like
get Walker scoball to play kid pool and
Deadpool 3 and Ryan Reynolds like the
tweet
so a lot of people are like oh snap is
it happening because now you know some
Insider reported kipple is going to be
in you know there as a variant and it's
like oh crap is it gonna be him because
you know have you seen the video of him
like quoting yeah yeah
I actually interviewed him and the Percy
Jackson cast and uh and Rick Greer
didn't once all in the same carpet yeah
there you go good kids that's getting
recreated it's not a kid but he was also
good sure yeah yeah yeah yeah well I I
think that would be a really cool idea
that would be and you know again both
Rashawn Levy Ryan Reynolds right so it's
like he Jackman's back for a reason
right like yeah something had to have
clicked correctly to make that happen
you know what I mean yeah and all these
other actors are back Kevin you know
there's a lot of faith I put in MCU I
always say trust the process yeah you
know I might not have my favorite you
know I might see a trailer and be like
ah I don't know but I'll still watch it
and then make and make my opinion I'm
not trying to on anything before I
see it no of course not yeah Deadpool
three uh I don't want to say it like I
think it's safe to be hyped about it you
know there's yeah I mean even if I and
I've said this in a few videos even if
you like take everything away that
insiders have said at the very least we
are getting Deadpool and Wolverine like
yeah Jackman and Ryan that's a buddy the
team up we wanted that is more than
enough for me yeah to just be super and
I still even though all these cameos are
said to happen I still want the focus to
be on like that the dynamic between I'm
just gonna say Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman because that's really cool it is
yeah right they are those characters so
it's like that is enough to be just
ecstatic about the movie and that's what
I am and then watch them fight like
physically fight because they can heal
so they're just gonna start stabbing
each other and you know just like yeah
uh endless bloodbath that like really is
never gonna end right I mean we've
watched Deadpool get ripped in half
before I mean yeah you know like so and
we get to finally see Wolverine again or
like like maybe amputating some folks
real you know like you know like who
knows I we saw it in Logan but I don't
know there's something about the comic
nature of a dead right right now yeah
not so serious yeah violence even though
it
can look like that a lot and you know
what you can finally get a proper
fastball special too
um which is my favorite they did them in
like the fox movies but like it never
looked right but like I just want
whoever's throwing Wolverine to look
bigger than Wolverine and you can't
really do that with Hugh Jackman
normally
because he is not five full no he is not
but that's a conversation for another
time
I love how when the picture first came
out of Ryan and uh Hugh as Wolverine you
edited to make you chap as well Bridge
smaller you're like there I fixed it I
fixed it I also put a cowl on him too
and I was just like this is what I want
that's uh yeah
I laughed so hard when I saw that
picture because at first I was like what
did he think Cindy was like oh he made
him shorter he made it perfect that was
incredibly calm again yeah
finally yeah that's so funny but yeah
lots lots of exciting things lots of
exciting things coming
um but man I am curious about what
they're gonna do with this new X-Men
movie but excited that they're hey
Kevin are you watching this you're
accepting writers right now do we count
I've had some ideas I'll get a story by
credit if you'll give it to me there you
go I need to write the whole thing I'll
take you take what we just did yeah or
what is the movie as you know bystanders
or something I used to always want to
play like oh night crawler or of course
for a while Iceman was like my favorite
but it's like you know I'm brown but
like
well if I could be in the MCU any in any
capacity X-Men would be pretty cool or
an agent for sure Atlas
I've always wanted to play Wolverine
always just I'm short I'm actually
taller than over in the car you're
taller than him but you have you you
have the big broad shoulders and stuff
yeah I'm like a bulky guy right yeah
yeah right but I could lean down Kevin
feige
lean down man and if not you know what
you're doing for Halloween this year
yeah right that that is like the oldest
photo I have of me in Halloween is me
dressed as Wolverine wow a long time
love yeah no I've I've Loved Wolverine
scent I mean I think I'm probably like
six in the picture that I have
um but yeah no he's been my favorite for
like freaking ever from watching like
you know the animated series and
everything to you know the first X-Men
film that came out like yeah he's
that's why I like Deadpool
three is gonna be such like a cool thing
to same thing with Secret Wars like yeah
just to finally see that character
played by an actor who does Wolverine a
lot of Justice in like a more comic book
friendly Universe hell yeah yeah I think
that we all wanted like we all wanted
mutants for so long and this is like a
really great way to see them in the MCU
you know in a big deal too so yeah in a
really big way and I think Kevin Fey's
gonna do it right because he's you know
worked he worked on that first X-Men
film yeah right in 2000 right he was a
junior producer and then just ever since
then he's you know worked his way up and
then president of Marvel Studios and
look where we at now so I have faith I
have excitement right sometimes we don't
want to get our hopes up but my hopes
are up because I think Deadpool 3 is
going to be fantastic but go ahead and
let us know what you think about
everything yeah tell us what you thought
tell us what you want to see from the
new X-Men movies since they're hiring
writers maybe it could be one of you if
you have a good idea sound off in the
comments I think go go Kevin feige read
the comments do it
but uh yeah so be sure to subscribe
because we are going to be talking about
Loki
October 3rd that was the date over third
coming out look out for that then and in
the meantime catch you on the next
episode